CHRIS YING: My
name's Chris Ying,
I'm the editor-in-chief
of a silly food
magazine called "Lucky Peach".
Among the things that my
job is good for-- or one
of the only things it's
good for-- is getting
to eat at lots of restaurants
that I otherwise would not
be able to.
I think in the last year,
since meeting Christopher,
I've had the pleasure of
eating at Meadowood five times
or something
ridiculous like that.
Too many times for him.
And I've eaten at a number
of fine dining restaurants
around the world
and certain trends
start to kind of appear
to you once you've
eaten at a number of two
or three Michelin star
restaurants.
And you start to see that
two-star Michelin restaurants
are kind of where a lot of
the innovative, exciting stuff
is happening.
And three Michelin
star restaurants
are where luxury and
over-the-top eating
happens and you're
just pampered.
And so when I went
to eat at Meadowood
for the very first time,
I thought, OK, well this
is going to be another
one of those situations
where I'm going
to have to loosen
my belt toward the
end of the meal
and just feel really
uncomfortable.
And I was just struck
eating at Meadowood.
Of all the restaurants
I've eaten,
it was this really
exciting, innovative place
where cooking was happening
that spoke to a specific place
in time and felt relevant.
And it was set in
this place that
was really luxurious
and beautiful,
but it didn't feel
stodgy in the way
that a three Michelin
star restaurant was--
and by the way, Meadowood is a
three Michelin star restaurant.
So anyway, I got to know
Christopher a little bit more
and found him to be
one of these guys who
is at the very forefront of
cooking in the world today.
Just pushing things forward and
speaking to his specific place
where Meadowood is, which
is in the Napa Valley.
So with that all
in mind, here we
are today in
Mountain View, which
is something a little bit
of a homecoming for you.
Can you give us a little
bit about-- can you
explain what the hell
I'm talking about?
CHRIS KOSTOW: Sure.
Thanks for coming
everyone, thank you.
My first chef job was
actually at Chez TJ,
which is on Villa
Street, in Mountain View.
It has been there for 28
years, 29 years, maybe.
Same owner, same paint
on the walls, same lamps.
And so, yeah.
So I moved to Mountain View
after I lived in San Francisco,
as the sous chef at Campton
Place for Daniel Humm.
And I wanted my first chef
job-- and having never been
to Mountain View or
anywhere near here--
it seemed close
enough to the city,
I think that was my thinking.
And I came and I lived
in what was more or less
a double-wide trailer
behind the restaurant, which
is where all the chefs
lived throughout their time
at the restaurant.
I spent two years there, we
had some degree of success
and moved on to Meadowood.
And I'm actually coming back to
do a dinner this coming Monday,
like a dinner
surrounding the book,
at Chez TJ, which
should be a lot of fun.
CHRIS YING: What brought
you to California
or northern
California originally?
CHRIS KOSTOW: I went to college
in New York, Hamilton College.
We don't produce a
lot of engineers.
It's all poets and finance.
And I had some idea that I
wanted to be in California,
having visited.
I had a roommate who was from
San Diego and those of you that
know that area
where Hamilton is,
like the center
of New York state.
It's like this
meteorological, bizarro world
where there's no sun ever.
It's really odd.
So I just wanted to go
somewhere that was sunny,
and I wanted to
go to California,
and I wanted to be a chef.
Those were like the
general ideas that I had.
So I ended up in San Diego,
living on the beach, cooking,
and eventually found my
way to San Francisco.
CHRIS YING: And at Hamilton,
you studied philosophy.
Not a lot of chefs
start their careers
by going to college
to study philosophy.
And it's interesting, I was
thinking about it being here
at Google, too.
A lot of people who are in this
industry, in the tech industry,
don't necessarily study
engineering or study anything
that pertains to a company
where they end up working.
But in the book, you
talk a little bit
about how your different
background informs
the way you cook or helps you.
Can you talk about
that a little bit?
CHRIS KOSTOW: I mean,
I think I should
say when it's written
that I studied philosophy,
I was terrible at it.
So I don't want
people thinking I
could have been this
acclaimed writer of philosophy
and instead chose to cook.
I don't think that
was an option.
Is there reverb or am I
just hearing that in my ear?
CHRIS YING: That's
definitely something.
CHRIS KOSTOW: OK.
Philosophy, like
cooking-- you study
philosophy in an
academic setting.
You're learning what
other people said,
you're studying those
things, with the end goal
in mind of maybe distilling
those things through the lens
of your own life and
creating an original idea.
I think that's sort of the idea.
And cooking's very
much like that.
You come up in
different kitchens
and you learn all these
different techniques.
You learn flavor profiles,
you learn skill sets.
But in the end, it's up to you,
after a certain period of time,
to take all that
information and create
something that's
uniquely your own.
And that takes a long time.
And that's the challenge with
young cooks now is they watch
a lot of TV where
everyone's a chef.
People want to create
their food, as they say.
But really that's the last
step of the whole thing.
It's about acquiring
a skill set.
I think the parallel is
that, is that eventually,
if you study well enough,
if you learn enough things,
and if you're honest
enough with yourself,
you can maybe, one day,
articulate your own vision.
CHRIS YING: So the book is
called "A New Napa Cuisine".
For those of us who are not
familiar with the old Napa
cuisine or what
came before, can you
explain what you're
trying to achieve?
What a new Napa cuisine is?
CHRIS KOSTOW: Sure.
And I'm very careful to
recognize the fact that there's
a lot of great chefs who have
already cooked in the Napa
Valley, well before
I ever got there.
Before I was born, frankly.
So it's not to say
that I'm the first guy
to grill in the Napa
Valley and cook nice food,
because that's
obviously not the case.
But I think we make the
parallel in the book
between architecture, as an
example, where, in the Napa
Valley, it was the arrival
of the wine industry
and the wealth that followed it.
It had a hodgepodge of
architectural styles.
There was like Spanish Revival
and there's a lot of Tuscan,
and there was
suburban McMansion.
There's all this stuff and
as the Valley slowed down
and started to maybe curate
something specific to it
in an architectural sense.
People specifically like
Howard Backen, who's
a renowned architect in the
area-- the Valley started
to create this more singular
architectural style that
had references to the
Valley's agrarian past,
had a very minimalist
aesthetic, it
was something that is now a
Napa Valley architectural style.
So in looking at
food in the same way,
there was always nice food.
Tra Vigne did great
Italian food for 15 years
and the French Laundry
does great food that's
of a French bend.
There was places like Cindy's
that were very America.
There's always good
food, but I don't
know if there was necessarily
the ambition, the desire,
or the wherewithal to
create a cooking that
really sprang from the place.
And, as we outline in
the book, that really
details those four
operating principles
which are: the use of
agriculture as a jumping off
point.
We do that by operating own
gardens, a nod to the Valley's
agricultural past.
It's using the materia
prima of the Valley--
it's the grains that
are milled nearby,
it's the use of the
bees and the honey
and all of those things,
the olive oil, all
that is found within the Valley.
There's the artisans, which
is a big part of what we do,
which is the curation
and commissioning
of our plates made in the Napa
Valley for the restaurant.
And then--
CHRIS YING: The materia--
CHRIS KOSTOW: Did I
say materia prima?
Growers, artisans.
CHRIS YING: Foraging.
CHRIS KOSTOW: Thank you.
Jesus Christ.
And then there's
the wilds, which
is utilizing the wild
elements of the Valley--
the foraging, the mushrooms,
the wild sorrells, all
of those things.
So really using those
things, most of which
were really untouched.
But in a culinary sense,
harnessing those things,
and starting to write a
new chapter in the Napa's
culinary history.
CHRIS YING: This idea
you're talking about,
of cooking food, of having a
restaurant that's specifically
of a place that's very
much tied to the artisans
and the wilds and
the materia prima,
is that something that
you brought with you
when you came to Meadowood?
Or is it something that you
learned when you arrived?
CHRIS KOSTOW: I think that
a lot of those words--
local and specificity
of place-- those
are definitely currents
in the food world.
I wasn't the first
guy to be like,
I want to cook food from here.
And maybe I was the first guy to
actually choose that particular
here, but there are
people, I think--
and there have been
for a long time--
sort of acting as
proponents of that idea.
But when I got
there, I certainly
had no idea that that was the
direction I wanted to take.
And as we talk
about in the book,
they were a lot
of "aha!" moments
when you start to realize that
Napa has a very thin veneer.
Meaning, there's this
assumption that it
is a certain kind of
place-- and it is.
It's a place where there's
money and wealth and wine
and tourists and
all these things.
But that veneer is very
thin and below that
is a lot of historical
and cultural depth
and opportunities to
pursue something unique.
So I think it was my
first couple of years
there that I started to
notice these things, it
was wild things growing,
if it was gaining
a small understanding of the
Valley's history and meeting
artisans.
It was a slow development.
And I really think it
came to focus years ago
and that was what
inspired the book.
CHRIS YING: So, like
you said, no one
had really thought
that Napa Valley was
one of these places
with a heritage that
could be unearthed from the
surface that we all know.
And the same goes
with Copenhagen
with Noma or Sao
Paulo and Alex Atala.
So is this idea of
uncovering what's
beneath the veneer
something that
could be translatable anywhere?
Can you do it in Mountain View?
Can you do it--
CHRIS KOSTOW: I think so.
It's important to not make it
an overly academic process.
You have to cook the food well.
You have to have nice product,
you need to cook it well,
otherwise it's an intellectual
exercise and has no value.
Food has to taste good.
So that's the jumping off point.
So, yeah, you could apply it
to a lot of different things.
And a lot of people frankly are,
in very forced, contrived ways,
trying to do that,
but in the end,
again, it's about being able to
cook well and pleasing people.
Everything else, I think
has to follow from that.
CHRIS YING: And so you
have these four tenets
that you talked about and you
talk about in the book, which
are the garden operations and
the artisans, the wilds of Napa
and the materia prima-- the
local earth and product.
So maybe we can go through
each of these a little bit
and talk about them.
Can you describe the garden
operations at Meadowood?
CHRIS KOSTOW: Sure.
When I got there, there
was a small garden
that was connected
to the property which
we use quite a bit and
we still use somewhat.
There's fruit trees and figs
and apples and quince and pears
and we still use
that quite a bit.
But we outgrew it and
developed a partnership
with a local Montessori
school which is just
on the other side of
the Silverado trail,
like a quarter mile
from the restaurant.
And we joined forces
with the school.
We utilized their land--
we have hoop houses
and we grow on about
two acres over there.
I work with the kids and
we do community lunches
at the restaurant.
It's as much an
agricultural effort
as it is a community outreach.
And that has really
proven to be the beating
heart of our creative process.
And we have a woman in
place there, Christine,
who is like the world's
greatest gardener, frankly.
We work very closely with her in
terms of, what are we planting?
When's it coming?
And we've really
gotten to a point--
we've gotten fairly good at it
over the past couple of years--
where maybe on a good month,
maybe 70% of what we're using
from a vegetable point of view
is coming from the garden.
CHRIS YING: That's
pretty incredible.
I don't know that people really
understand, that's a lot.
CHRIS KOSTOW: That's a lot.
CHRIS YING: I actually wanted
to back up just a second.
How many people here
have been to Meadowood?
OK, so I'll just
give a brief on what
this restaurant is like
for the rest of you.
It is tucked away on a
sprawling resort that's
just one of those places that's
impossible not to love being.
Eating at Meadowood is this
really holistic experience.
You don't accidentally
show up at Meadowood.
You go out of your
way to get there.
You stay where you eat.
So if you drink-- you
will drink and then
you will be wheeled by
Meadowood's capable staff
into your room and
deposited into your bed.
CHRIS KOSTOW: On the ground.
CHRIS YING: Onto the ground,
it's not a full service thing.
So it's part of this
tradition, Meadowood
is, that not a lot of
people are familiar
with and not a lot of us have
experienced in our lifetime.
And you talk in the
book about wanting
to be a part of this
tradition, wanting
to be a destination restaurant.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
CHRIS KOSTOW: Yeah, I
always liked the idea,
even when I was in Mountain
View, of not having
casual diners.
You wanted people to come who
really wanted to eat that food.
You didn't want them to
struggle to get there, per se,
but you want it to
be a deliberate act.
And I think that enables one,
as a chef, a lot more freedom
in determining
maybe what they do.
And having worked
in Europe a lot,
I liked that idea of these
restaurants and properties
set away from everything
else, because there's
this transformative separation
that happens when you-- and
even if you're driving
up from the city
and you're driving through
Napa-- you're already relaxed.
You drive on this beautiful
property, it's something
of an escape and,
therefore, much more
of an immersive experience than
if you just pull up in a taxi
and walk in the front
door of a restaurant.
And you feel that very
much in the restaurant.
When you're in the
room, people are
incredibly happy to be there.
And that makes our
job a lot easier.
It makes for a much more
enjoyable experience.
So that was always
something I liked.
And that idea of-- we talk
about in the book, that
aubergiste mentality of,
you're on the front steps
of your place sweeping and
people are journeying to you.
I like that a lot.
CHRIS YING: And you
guys have become
a part of this local community
of nearby St. Helena.
I've walked down the street
with you and your family,
you just get stopped by
everybody, like, you owe me $5.
CHRIS KOSTOW: Exactly.
CHRIS YING: So let's go back
to the garden a little bit.
You were just saying that when
things are really clicking,
you can take up to 70% of the
vegetables in the restaurant.
So how do you and your cooks
interact with the garden?
Does the garden
inform what you cook?
Are you telling the
gardener I need four carrots
to come out of the ground today?
CHRIS KOSTOW: It's a
little bit of both.
We're determining what
we're going to plant,
it's like, we want to do this
this year, this, this, this.
But then you forget.
And then, all of a sudden,
it's like, hey, there's
carrots coming tomorrow.
So there's a little bit of that.
But there's also, we know
that this is in the ground.
So from a systemic point of
view, on a day-to-day basis,
we order from the garden.
We know what's coming.
Christine sends out these order
lists, we order what we need.
So there's the part of it where
the kitchen informs the garden
and says, plant this.
But to a much greater degree,
it's, hey, this is coming up.
And limits and
restraints very much,
for us, very much
fuel creativity.
It's a lot harder
to create good food
when you have every
ingredient at your disposal.
For me, it's a lot
easier when it's
like, hey, we have
kohlrabi coming.
CHRIS YING: As you guys
flip through these books,
you'll see a lot of the dishes
that Meadowood-- the plating,
specifically-- are
very much focused
or feature the vegetable.
Feature the herb and the
fruit and the vegetable
as this beautiful,
precious commodity
and highlights them over
the more expensive--
over this caviar or the
foie gras or whatever.
Is this something that you've
always emphasized vegetables?
Or is it something that having
a garden has increased in you?
CHRIS KOSTOW: I think
once you understand
the process as a chef, you
realize how much harder it
is to grow that
carrot than it is
to order some caviar
from the caviar guy.
And that's why.
You know, we don't shave
truffles table-side.
We're trying to get these
porcinis just right so we
can shave the porcini table-side
that were forged by our guy.
It's a way of showing
what we value.
Luxury's great.
I love truffles, I like caviar.
But for me, that just doesn't
have the same degree of value.
It's that thing
that you-- not just
that you planted and you grew--
but you created the garden,
hired the people, and
worked with the school,
and tilled the earth,
and, I mean, it's like--
and you get this little
carrot as a result.
Not to mention that
they taste pretty good.
CHRIS YING: One of the
things that I've always
loved, like eating
at the restaurant
and noticed that sometimes those
ingredients, like the caviar,
the truffle, are literally
hidden underneath vegetables.
You don't even know they're
there until you eat it
and I'm kind of
like, don't you want
to show off your Lamborghini?
CHRIS KOSTOW: Some people would
rather show it off a little,
I'm not gonna lie.
CHRIS YING: Do you have a
hard time ever with guests--
and Meadowood's not a cheap
restaurant, in case anybody had
any ideas that it was
a cheap Tuesday night
place or anything.
CHRIS KOSTOW: Well, Google said
they would subsidize, actually,
all of your meals.
CHRIS YING: If you all
look under your seats,
there's a gift certificate.
CHRIS KOSTOW: Yeah, there's
a free dinner for everybody.
CHRIS YING: I've always
wondered this of Meadowood
and of some other top-tier
restaurants today.
Like, do you ever have to have
that conversation with a diner
to justify the
price when you have
a very vegetable-focused menu?
And not to say that
it's a vegetarian--
CHRIS KOSTOW: Yeah, right.
You know, it does happen.
But I think it happens
the same percentage
that it happens anywhere when
people don't get their steak.
So it's not a big
problem that we have.
It's about how you
tell the story.
It's not about preaching
to someone, saying, no, you
don't understand.
This carrot took my blood,
sweat-- you don't say that.
Ideally, you weave a
tale of certain narrative
that engages the diner
in what you're doing
and they're as excited
about it as you are.
If you have to lecture your
guest so they understand
the value of things, you're
doing your job terribly.
And if you're making
things taste delicious,
I really feel, especially
at that price point,
the diners are so sophisticated
and frequent those places
enough, that they're equally
pleased to have something
that's delicious and
different and special.
CHRIS YING: And that is totally
the experience of Meadowood,
is you feel things are
stimulating and interesting,
but never challenging
the point of displeasure.
You're not trying to--
CHRIS KOSTOW: I mean, you know.
When you eat at a lot of
these restaurants that
are on the certain lists and
are these well-known places,
you'll have dishes
that taste like shit.
Would you agree with that?
CHRIS YING: Sure.
CHRIS KOSTOW: You have
dishes that don't taste good.
And that's the thing that
we have to wrestle with is,
everything has to taste good.
We are trying to be
the tip of the sword,
in terms of pushing
things forward,
in terms of being a
little cutting edge.
But there's no room for failure.
The end result
can't be a failure.
What the guest sees
So it may be that's the
difference between two
and three stars.
And that's maybe what we do is
so odd, in that the two's can
make some mistakes, but they're
also pushing really hard.
We're pushing really hard,
but we have no net below us.
And that's pretty challenging.
CHRIS YING: But I think
that what-- sorry,
not to argue about how
great your restaurant
and prove to you.
CHRIS KOSTOW: Unbelievable.
CHRIS YING: I've felt often
times that at a three Michelin
star restaurant, there
are certain things they're
obligated to do for you.
At the end of the meal,
you have to have some--
after you've eaten
tons of stuff,
you've got to have
some tchotchkes
and you've got to end
with a big, fat piece
of dry-aged steak that
you don't possibly want.
And I never felt like there
were any gestures at Meadowood
that you felt obliged to do.
And which is the most
impressive part about Meadowood
is that you're able to not
give those things, necessarily,
and yet maintain
the three stars.
CHRIS KOSTOW: I
mean, maybe one day
Michelin will say, wait, you're
not giving away tchotchkes.
But that goes to the
way we look at it,
is like, we are going to go in
the direction we think is best.
And I keep thinking of the
tchotchke thing-- a lot
of three star restaurants,
you finish dinner,
they give you all this stuff.
You know, cookies for the
next day and all this stuff.
And I like the idea
that you leave your meal
with just the memories of
it and it's a nice feeling
and you don't find stale cookies
on your counter the next day.
But that's one of those things.
I don't want to say it's a trap,
but that's one of those things
that we consciously don't do.
And so maybe we'll be
one of those two star
restaurants one day.
CHRIS YING: Another thing
that you guys don't do
is you don't serve
all of your food
on the same fine
porcelain white china.
Which brings us
into another section
of the book, which
is the artisans.
So could you tell us a
little bit about the plates?
CHRIS KOSTOW: Sure.
That's another thing
that's very trendy
and I think it's actually a
great trend within the industry
is the use of ceramics.
If you start studying
the history of ceramics
and the role of ceramics in
restaurants and in dining,
you really start to see
how silly it is sometimes
when you're curating food so
specifically to then go buy
a plate from someone and put
all these things that you
made on a plate
they just bought.
There's a bit of a
disconnect there.
The artisan project
began with a couple
different artisans in
the Valley, all of whom
we still use.
And it is now culminated
in this new partnership
that I'm doing with a ceramicist
named Richard Carter, who's
in Pope Valley, which
is Napa County, just
on the other side
of the mountain.
And if you read the
book, that's actually
where we shot all the food.
And with the exception
of the chapter that
deals with the
plates, all the food
is actually shot on surfaces
from this gentleman's
19th century homestead.
The thinking was the way a
band would go-- you know,
Dylan and the band
used to go to Woodstock
and record in the basement
of the house there.
And bands will retire to certain
studios and places to record
and the feeling of that
place bleeds into the music.
That was our thinking
with the book.
So we shot the
food not on plates,
but on all the kiln shelves
from his wood-fired kiln
and on the glass
and the wood and all
the varied tactile surfaces
that you find there.
So part and parcel to
that is we're actually
launching a new plate
line, me and him,
and it's this
collaboration that's
now reaching this point
if we ever get it done.
But I really found
that, to do what
we want to do and to make each
dish a self-contained idea,
maybe one reason
we're able to get away
with the stuff we get away with
is because it feels like you're
being told a very big story.
And the reason it
feels as such is
because each thing
you're given is
like a little sentence
or a little chapter.
So without the vessels
that fit the food
it's a lot harder to do that.
We do a dish now, it's like
a pork collar acorn miso
that we make and it sits on
a plate that's burnt orange.
And the whole dish,
it looks like fall.
It's beautiful, it makes
sense, it touches all the bases
that we touch, and it's a
totally self-contained idea.
That dish would not be impactful
if we put it on something
we bought.
And that's the goal in the
distance, is to really, really,
really make that
point really well.
And that's an expensive
and painstaking process
to really develop pieces of clay
that fit the food that you're
thinking of in your mind and
have those two things come
to fruition at the same thing.
That's really challenging.
But the goal is,
throughout the meal,
you're stunned by the
overall beauty of what's
being put in front of you.
CHRIS YING: There's
a line in the book
that I really, really liked
and talking about that luxury
aspect and this idea of a new
kind of luxury at Meadowood.
And that was when you said
that specificity costs money.
And it kind of flies in the face
of most other business models
in this day and age,
where it's like, you've
got to provide
everything to every one
and then show them
ads or-- sorry, guys.
CHRIS KOSTOW: I didn't say
that, I did not say that, guys.
The ads are great.
CHRIS YING: All the
plates at Meadowood
have a tiny, little ad.
But I just noted that that's an
interesting way to look at it.
What they're paying
for is not necessarily
just you sourcing out the most
expensive thing of everything.
CHRIS KOSTOW: I think
that's more and more
valuable and relevant
as we, as a society,
become more and more
build-your-own Starbucks
coffee.
I did a talk the other day with
the head of R&D of Starbucks
and she's like, we 180,000
possible combinations.
Who wants 180,000-- like,
who really needs that?
So there's something nice
about you sitting in our room.
We got you.
We got you, we have put so
much thought into that potato
because I don't want you to.
I just want you to
appreciate it, maybe
but definitely enjoy it.
CHRIS YING: And at
Meadowood, the reservationist
will speak about
dietary restrictions,
but when you sit down at
table, there's no menu.
CHRIS KOSTOW: There's
no menu, yeah.
CHRIS YING: You're just
strapped in for ride.
CHRIS KOSTOW: The thinking was,
it's not about taking control
away, it's that I don't want you
to look at a menu and be like,
OK, I'm getting chicken next
and then I'm getting this next.
That makes it possible for it to
be a really immerse experience.
We want there to
be surprise and we
want to be able to
play with the guest.
It's not like, OK, I've
got three more courses,
one of which is beef.
CHRIS YING: So, the next section
of the book is about the wilds.
And you talked in
the introduction
about this section, thinking
that this trend of foraging
and finding ingredients
out in the world
was not really for you.
You thought it was a trend.
But then you tell
a great story that
involves a certain
character named Charlie.
If you could maybe
communicate that.
CHRIS KOSTOW: Charlie is a dog.
He's a half German
shepherd-- this
is my wife, Martina over here.
It's our dog.
A lot of these aha! moments
that we talked about.
And we used to live in a
little-- we were still dating--
in a house that backed
up into this estuary that
runs to the river and I used to
take Charlie there as a puppy.
And he used to run
around and that's
when you'd notice that there's
pea-- P-E-A-- pea growing.
There's wild plums,
there's eucalyptus,
there's these huge oaks
and all of the acorns,
there's all this stuff
just growing there.
And it's very Willy Wonka,
like everything's edible.
And that was the connection.
I still think a lot
of foraging is silly.
And people think that
just because they went out
in the morning and got it
doesn't mean it tastes good.
I think there's a lot of that.
But we found what we
want and what we look for
and what we get.
And I think that, for
me, the importance
of the historical
connection to the place,
we still find mortar
stones along the river that
are mortar rocks from when the
Indians would grind acorns.
We still pick the
same blackberry bushes
that people did
hundreds of years ago
or use Indian paintbrush
or the mustard flowers
that bloom in the spring.
There's something--
yeah, it tastes good
and that's the most important--
but that addition of meaning
and value and the
amount of depth
that that can lead to a story
as a whole is really, really
powerful.
And sometimes you have
to go find that stuff.
CHRIS YING: I have a couple
of questions about that idea.
just underneath our noses in
Saint Helena and Napa Valley
are these rocks
that Wappo Indians
would use to grind
acorns and there's
a whole levels of stories
underneath what we see now.
So could you tell
us a little bit
about how it is you came
to know this history?
And what is the difference
between the Napa that we all
see when we go wine-tasting
for the weekend
and what's underneath?
CHRIS KOSTOW: There's these
really good books by-- his name
escapes me-- one's called
"The Far Side Of Eden",
James Conaway.
And these are really
modern, actually.
How did the wine industry start?
And his next book is
called-- I can't remember.
But it's about what happened
in the '90s, Silicon
Valley, the first
dot-com boom, what
that did to the Valley,
the influx of wealth.
So then you start
to say OK, this
is why things are
the way they are.
This is why there's
a wine trade.
all this stuff.
And then you start looking
back and understanding
what the role of probation
was, what the cash crops were
before there were
grapes, why the CIA is
this huge
monastery-looking building.
Why?
You start to learn
all these things.
And I would go to the
Historical Society-- we still
work at the Historical Society.
My staff has to go
take historical tour
of the town and all this stuff.
And for me, I'm a nerd about
that stuff and I like it.
But also, not just
in terms of cooking
where you are,
from living there,
I think that provides a
certain depth of importance.
CHRIS YING: I mean, short
of assigning homework
to your diners before
they come in to eat--
is there a way
for you to Google?
Do you think diners
would benefit,
do you think they would
enjoy the meal more if they
understood that you took
this walk on this trail that
used to be, et
cetera, et cetera?
CHRIS KOSTOW: Some yes, some no,
but the success of the dinner
can't be contingent upon
their understanding of it.
CHRIS YING: And so the
last section of the book
is divided into is
the materia prima.
And it also speaks to
the very bones of Napa.
Can you explain that idea?
CHRIS KOSTOW: That's
probably the hardest part,
because wine-growing
land in the Napa Valley
can fetch a quarter of a million
to half a million dollars,
meaning there's not
a lot of small farms.
Because there's a lot more
money in grapes than there
is in chickens.
So for us, that's been
our biggest struggle,
is finding people who produce
things at a high quality,
protein-wise.
And when we have to make a
decision between something
that's local and shitty
and somethings that's
not local and good,
we're going to have
to get what's not
local and good.
So that's been a challenge.
And we've now found someone
who raises pigs for us,
someone who raises guinea
hens, but that search
is really challenging.
But sometimes it takes working
with the people to help them.
Like we have this walnut
oil from Rancho [INAUDIBLE],
which is this old Spanish land
grant, and this lovely woman
and her husband--
who I know-- they've
revived the walnut orchard, they
make this really nice walnut
oil.
But sometimes you have
to help a little bit,
maybe create other
customers for them
so it's a financially
viable system.
And then that concept
of what is sustainable.
There's also economic
sustainability.
And in order to make some
of these things possible,
you have to create that.
And you're using
the mill in town,
their stones aren't that sharp.
So I might need to
put them in touch
with someone who
sharpens millstones.
And it seems like a lot of work
to get flour, but in the end
the flour's really
good and you've
done good things
for a lot of people.
CHRIS YING: Like most of us
food nerds in California,
you talk in the beginning
when you couldn't really
afford to buy cookbooks,
one of your first cookbooks
being the Chez Panisse Cafe
Cookbook and anybody who
is a, again,
California food fatty,
our education begins
with Chez Panisse
and is tied to this idea
of California cuisine.
Where does Meadowood
lie in this narrative
of California cuisine.
CHRIS KOSTOW: I think there's
a lot of chefs in California
who are in that tradition.
I mean, they're
all that tradition.
I think maybe what sets
Meadowood apart maybe, again,
is that idea of operating at
that old-school hospitality,
ideally perfect
execution, world,
while still remaining
true to those tenets.
Because it's easy to remain
true to those tenants,
when you're just like, hey,
we've got green beans, hey,
we can sautee them
up with some bacon.
I used what's in the garden.
That's, while super-honorable
is kind of easy.
When it's like, hey,
we've got green beans,
there's 70 people coming
for a $400-a-pop dinner,
what are you going
to do with it?
So I don't mean to imply that
we're doing California cuisine,
but we're doing it better.
We're just making it
really hard on ourselves.
CHRIS YING: And it
is a new idea that
took California-- northern
California, specifically--
a long time to catch up, was,
yes, California cuisine is
a great and beautiful philosophy
and important to the overall
advancement of American
cooking, but we shouldn't just
stop at that point.
CHRIS KOSTOW: Yes.
CHRIS YING: It's
great that everyone
can serve those green
bean, it would also
be great if there
were restaurants
that did something else
with those green beans.
CHRIS KOSTOW: I think your very
good friend had made a comment.
CHRIS YING: Yeah, some
figs or something.
You mentioned just a
minute ago, the influx
of money during the
first dot-com boom.
And in the book you
talk about, there's
certain laws in Napa
that prevent you
from having businesses.
It's protecting agriculture
and things like that.
What makes Napa Valley
an interesting place
to work in and run a restaurant?
CHRIS KOSTOW: I mean, you're
in what really is an agrarian
setting which has been
incredible value in terms
of creating food
that's of a terroir.
And you're an hour
and fifty minutes
from the most sophisticated
city in America.
That's a very rare thing.
You have people who are already
coming there, people of means.
You have a bit of
a captive audience
and they used to be
a seasonal audience.
Now, Napa is literally
a year-round destination
for a lot of people.
People who by nature
of they're coming there
obviously appreciate
food and wine.
That's a pretty good
situation to be in,
provided you're doing
the right kind of work
in capturing those people.
CHRIS YING: Toward
the end of the book,
you have a really
beautiful final essay
talking about this
idea of the new Napa
cuisine and your
commitment to this area
and being a steward of it
and advancing these ideas
and taking your own part
in this long history.
How do these ideas
spread beyond Meadowood?
Do you think that your
cooks will go and stay
in the Napa Valley?
Like, how do you intend
for this to play out
in the next ten,
15, 20, 30 years?
CHRIS KOSTOW: I think
the biggest challenge
to your earlier
point is, there's not
a lot of restaurant
spaces in Napa Valley.
I mean, there's some, but it
suffers from the same problems
that San Francisco
does for young cooks
and young entrepreneurs,
the cost of living
being what it is, the cost of
opening a restaurant in Napa
being what it is.
But I already see that happening
and it'll be one or two.
It'll take time.
But I do see that happening.
And I think what'll
be interesting
and both what I'm going to do
and what the next generation
will do or what the
next cooks will do
is it'll be at all sorts
of different price points.
I mean, there's a lot of
restaurant-y concept things
that we want to do that all
fit within the ethos of what
we talked about in the book
that are totally different.
And, again, I feel like every
time we find a new product
or find a new way of
using what's around us,
I genuinely think we help a
lot of people when we do it,
provided we're doing
it responsibly.
That walnut oil example or
the mill or whatever it is.
So I think when you're doing
good things for people,
people support you.
I think that we have a lot
of goodwill in our community
for what we do, which
I think affords us
the opportunity to build
a lot of businesses,
both myself and my team.
CHRIS YING: I have reached
the end of my piece of paper.
CHRIS KOSTOW: You did a
really good job, though.
CHRIS YING: Which means maybe
it's somebody else's turn,
if anybody has any
questions to ask Mr. Kostow?
AUDIENCE: What's your favorite
restaurant in wine country?
Basically, where
should I eat next?
I've already been
to your restaurant.
CHRIS YING: It
changes seasonally.
CHRIS KOSTOW: Yeah, it sure
is different, I would come!
Where did we go for dinner?
We have a little one,
so we don't eat out
as much as we used to.
I like Redwood.
I think they do a nice
pizzas and stuff at Redwood.
Cook is nice in Saint Helena.
It's cute and fun.
AUDIENCE: Speaking
of little ones,
can you get them to
eat any of your food?
CHRIS KOSTOW: She eats well,
she eats a lot of tofu,
a lot of eggs, she eats pasta.
She freaks out over pasta.
But I'm not making
the pasta by hand
from the flour
ground from the grain
to the mill with the old
guy in period attire.
Yeah, there's only some
many hours in the day.
But she eats well,
she eats very well.
AUDIENCE: It's important.
AUDIENCE: So, okay, this
one's about-- how do you
go about finding staff?
And training your staff
to embody the same tenets
that you have?
And making sure that's
conveyed to all the diners?
And keeping that whole
level consistent?
CHRIS KOSTOW: I mean,
if I believe in it,
I'm enthused about it.
All I have to do is
communicate about it
consistently and effectively.
In terms of finding
people, we're
a bit immunized from
the staffing challenges
that right now are endemic in
restaurants, in the Bay Area
specifically.
Because we've acclimated
to the restaurant.
A, we have tons and tons
and tons of applicants,
but we also don't really
have any turnover.
I mean, how many [INAUDIBLE]
one of said staff,
I mean they said in the
kitchen, how many people quit?
Zero, right?
CHRIS YING: He's going to
take this opportunity to--
CHRIS KOSTOW: Chef, I've
been meaning to talk to you.
I think we don't have the
turnover that restaurants do
and we don't have the turnover
that high-end restaurants tend
to have.
We have a thing called
TRAM U, The Restaurant
of Meadowood University.
Where it's going to
the historical society,
it's going to Sturgeon
ranch, it's going foraging,
they go to wineries.
They are immersed.
It's hard, because
everyone's so busy,
but we try to immerse
everybody in what we're doing.
AUDIENCE: Alright, I'd like
to thank Chris for coming.
I'll give him a
round of applause.